at this stage still ongoing uh what's
your take on who might be with this is
this necessarily an is attack do you
think it seems very likely that this is
an Islamic state obviously it's very
early stage the incident still seems to
be ongoing but given where Islamic state
is in terms of its current strategy and
activity they are probably the most
likely perpetrator and if manic state as
one of your previous speakers mentioned
is under extreme pressure in itself
declared Caliphate in Iraq and Syria and
it's specifically for that reason that
we're seeing this high tempo of attacks
both in Europe and in other parts of the
world in South Asia in the Middle East
and and elsewhere because the group is
trying to appear as still a strong
entity its recruitment is likely to
suffer as its Caliphate shrinks because
that is such a central part of the
message and hence it needs to do other
things and so yes the most likely
perpetrator is Islamic state but this
obviously is still very early stage and
so as we look at these pictures here
tonight you say it bears all the
hallmarks of an is attack and this will
be the latest in several over recent
monton what does this tell us about the
way we're approaching security across
Europe it's very difficult to and to try
and confront this threat because it
changes all the time if we look at the
Paris attacks Islamic state sent trained
militants back to Europe to carry out
those attacks but since then it its
strategy has has changed again and in a
number of recent attacks it has used
local sympathizers to carry out the
attacks who themselves haven't had
Millicent training they've perhaps had
contact with trained militant some sort
of sleeper cell but it's been local
sympathizers who've actually carried out
the violence so they're much more
difficult to detect and disrupt and it's
it's that combined with the fact
that the tactics continually evolve and
continually change that makes it a very
very difficult thing to to confront